Imagine you're staring at this incredibly dense 30-page scientific manuscript.
Oh, we've all been there.
Right. You're deep in the weeds of the methodology section. Your eyes are just completely glazing over. And the text feels like this, I don't know, this impenetrable wall of jargon and math.
Yeah, it's exhausting.
It really is. And if you're anything like me, you probably find yourself thinking, I wish I could just knock on this wall, wake up the authors, and ask them to run my specific data through their brand new method.
Just like, do the work for me, please.
Exactly. I mean, wouldn't it be incredible if the paper itself wasn't just a document, but like an active participant? If it could actually execute the science for you? Well, today's deep dive is about making that a reality.
It's we're really looking at a complete paradigm shift here in how we interact with scientific knowledge. Yeah. Because for centuries, I mean, we've treated research papers as these static passive artifacts. Right. They're just a PDF sitting in a folder on your desktop. But the
framework we are exploring today completely shatters that model.
It does. And we are exploring this through a brand new paper, which was actually published in Nature today, September 16th, 2026.
Hot off the presses.
Literally today. It's by Jiaqing Miao, Joe Datis, Yaohui Zhang, Jonathan Pritchard and James Zhu out of Stanford. And it is brilliantly titled Reimagining Research Papers as Interactive and Reliable AI Agents. It's a
bold title.
It is. The core claim here is that they've built a system which they call paper to agent that takes a static PDF and it's usually messy underlying code and transforms it into a a virtual corresponding author. Right. But to really
unpack this, you know, we aren't just looking at the Stanford paper today. We have a whole stack of background sources from earlier attempts to AI code generation. to the latest literature on AI-driven scientific discovery to some, frankly, pretty sobering research on the cybersecurity risks
of doing all this.
Yeah, the security stuff is wild. But we really need that broader context because to appreciate what Paper2Agent is actually doing, you know, we have to look at the incredibly broken state of scientific software right now.
Oh, man. The dependency hell.
Exactly. If you have ever tried to reproduce someone else's computational research, you already know the pain we're talking about here.
You download a zip file from a paper published like three years ago and just nothing works.
Nothing works. It is a massive problem. And to put actual numbers to that pain, we can look at a 2022 study by Trasovic and colleagues. Right. They systematically analyzed replication packages hosted in the Harvard Dataverse. So these are the code
repositories that scientists upload to explicitly prove their work is reproducible. OK,
so this is supposed to be the good code.
Supposed to be, yeah. And they found that a staggering 74% of the R files simply failed to run.
Wow. Wait, 74 percent.
74 percent. They crashed. They had missing dependencies or they called for local files that just didn't exist on the server.
Nearly three quarters of published code just flat out fails. So naturally, as I'm reading this new Stanford paper, my first instinct is, well, pure skepticism. Because if the baseline human written code is already that broken, how does throwing a
large language model at it solve anything? I mean, if you tell an AI to figure out a broken script, doesn't it just get confused and start making things up?
Yeah, the hallucination problem. Exactly.
We saw a framework earlier this year, Paper 2 Code, by CEO and colleagues. And while that was impressive, it had this exact vulnerability, right?
Bringing up paper to code is actually the perfect way to highlight the breakthrough here because those earlier systems, what they do is they read the text of the methodology section, analyze the logic, and then they attempt to generate the code from scratch.
Okay.
The AI basically acts like a junior developer writing a fresh script based on a set of written instructions.
Which means it's guessing. It's hallucinating the implementation based on the PDF, which might be missing crucial steps that the original authors just forgot to write down.
Exactly. And that is where Paper 2 Agent pivots entirely. It does not generate the core mathematical code from scratch.
Oh, it doesn't?
No. Instead, it wraps the paper's existing code base and rigorously validates it. It acts as like an automated environment manager and a quality control system for the code the authors already wrote.
Okay.
So it isn't trying to invent the math. It's just trying to package the author's math so that it actually executes.
Okay, let's unpack the mechanics of that. Because taking a code base that has a 74% failure rate and, you know, wrapping it sounds like an absolute nightmare. How does the AI actually pull that off without a human holding its hand?
Well, it relies on a multi-agent pipeline built on top of clod code. So you can think of it as a small team of highly specialized AI workers rather than just one general chatbot.
Okay, a team.
Right. First, you have the environment agent, and this one tackles that trisovic problem head on. Its entire job is just to read the repository, look at the error messages when the code inevitably crashes, and iteratively figure out which specific versions of which libraries need to be
installed to stabilize everything.
So it's basically doing the agonizing, you know, trial and error grunt work that a grad student would normally do on a Tuesday afternoon.
Exactly that. It just bashes its head against the wall until the environment is stable. Nice. And once it is, the extraction agent takes over. This one reads the methodology text and translates the core algorithms from the code base into discrete executable tools.
Okay.
And then comes the most critical worker, which is the testing agent.
And this is where we get to the locking mechanism, right? Which is Paper 2 Agent's ultimate defense against hallucination.
Yes, precisely.
Because if I understand the architecture correctly, before any tool is finalized, this testing agent runs the original author's example data through the newly wrapped code.
Right.
And then it looks at the output, say like a CSV file or a generated graph, and it compares it value by value to the tables and figures actually published in the PDF.
It validates the tool against the paper's own reported reality.
That's so smart.
It really is. If the numbers generated by the code don't perfectly match the numbers printed in the Nature or Science article, the tool is rejected.
It just throws it out.
Yeah. But if they do match, the tool is permanently locked. It becomes a verified capability of that specific AI agent.
I want to talk about how this is actually packaged for the user, because the Stanford team uses something called an MCP server. Now, for you listening, MCP stands for Model Context Protocol.
Right, the new standard.
Yeah, it's essentially the new industry standard that allows an AI assistant to securely reach out and use external tools. And Paper2Agent builds a custom MCP server for every single research paper.
Right, and it comprises three elements.
Yeah, the MCP tools, the MCP resources, and the MCP prompts.
Right, and to visualize how those three elements interact, you know, you can think of the MCP prompt as a highly detailed recipe. It guides the AI step-by-step through a really complex scientific workflow.
Okay, the recipe.
Then the MCP resources are your pantry ingredients. These are the static assets, like the actual manuscript text, the supplementary data files, the metadata.
Got it.
And finally, the MCP tools are your kitchen appliances. These are the locked executable functions we just talked about that actually slice, dice, and process the data.
So when you're chatting with the paper agent, the prompt tells the AI how to use the tools to process the resources.
Exactly.
And because those tools are locked and validated, the whole server can be hosted remotely on a platform like Hugging Face. I mean, you don't have to install anything on your laptop. Nothing at all. You just plug the server into your cloud interface, and suddenly you're conversing with an
entity that both understands the theory and has the executable hands to run the populations.
It's amazing. But, you know, the theory is beautiful, but the true test of any computational framework is how it handles the messy, high-dimensional reality of modern biology.
Oh, absolutely. Which brings us to Alpha Genome. When I read this section of the Nature paper, I honestly had to reread the numbers.
They're pretty wild.
Alpha Genome is a massive, incredibly dense foundation model for genomic data. The Stanford team unleashed Paper 2 agent on it. And running on a standard laptop without a human intervening at all, the framework built 22
validated locked tools for Alpha Genome in about 45 minutes. And the API cost to do all that reasoning, $14.
14 bucks. When you consider that bringing a new postdoc up to speed on a code base like Alpha Genome can take, what, weeks of reading documentation and troubleshooting dependencies?
Oh, at least weeks.
Yeah. So a $14 automated onboarding is just staggering.
Let's talk about the benchmark tests they ran, though, because they didn't just stop at building the tools. They tested how well the agent could actually answer questions.
Right. They had to prove it works.
Yeah. So if you ask the Alpha Genome agent a novel query, something that requires combining tools in a way not explicitly outlined in the paper's basic tutorials, it scored 100% accuracy.
And to give you a baseline for why that matters, right, if you take the standard cloud model and just give it direct access to the exact same GitHub repository, its accuracy drops to 78.7%. Okay. And if you use a specialized bioinformatics AI, like
Biomni, it drops to 56%. Wait,
why does standard cloud struggle so much when it can see all the same code?
Well, because scene code is very different from understanding the validated execution pathways. Standard Cloud just gets lost in the weeds of the raw scripts.
Oh, I see.
It doesn't have the locked MCP tools or those guiding MCP prompts that Paper 2 agents specifically engineered out of the paper's methodology. And, you know, the gap widens even further when you move from targeted queries to open-ended researcher-style questions.
Right, the questions where a PI just says, hey, run this new data set through the pipeline and tell me what the major biological pathways are.
Yeah, the vague stuff.
On those open-ended tasks, the Paper 2 agent scored 82.7% accuracy, completely crushing the baseline clot, which sat at like 56.7%.
They further prove the usability by identifying a tool called Scampi. Now, for listeners who haven't worked in computational biology, Scampi is a cornerstone for single cell data analysis.
And single cell data is notoriously finicky. I mean, you're dealing with matrices of tens of thousands of individual cells against tens of thousands of genes. There's noise. There are dead cells. The filtering steps are highly subjective.
It requires an immense amount of human intuition. Yet the scampi agent was able to successfully reproduce a human researcher's entire single cell processing pipeline.
Wow.
The human user only had to provide a single file path to the raw data set. That's it.
Just point it at the data.
Exactly. From there, the agent knew exactly how to filter the dead cells, normalize the expression matrices, cluster the data, and generate the visualizations, all based on the protocols established in the original paper.
It is literally like having a tireless genius co-author living inside your machine. You hand them the raw data, and they instantly know exactly which knobs to turn on this incredibly complex mathematical instrument, because they essentially are the instrument.
Yeah, that's a great way to put it.
But here is where we need to dive a layer deeper. Because the system isn't just flawlessly regurgitating the paper's methods. It actually reasons about the underlying science. And in one specific case, it flat out disagreed with the
human authors.
Oh, yeah. This is the SORT T1 discovery, which the Stanford team proudly highlights as a feature, not a bug.
Okay, so the user prompts the alpha genome agent to interpret why a specific genetic variant is heavily associated with LDL cholesterol levels. Right. Now, if you read the original published text of the alpha genome paper, the human authors focus their narrative on two
specific genes, cell SR2 and PSRC1. Correct. But when the AI agent runs its tools, looks at the raw statistical outputs, and synthesizes the biology, it tells the user, no, the most likely causal gene driving this cholesterol trait is actually SRT1.
And this is an hallucination. The agent provides the biological receipts to back it up. It points to a massive quantile score, which is essentially a statistical ranking showing extremely high activity for sort one expression, specifically in liver tissue.
Furthermore, it surfaces the biological context that the sort one gene encodes a protein directly involved in the secretion of cholesterol.
So wait, why did the original human authors ignore it?
Well, they didn't completely ignore it. I mean, all three of those genes show strong statistical associations in the raw data. But human scientists are storytellers, right?
That's true.
When writing a paper, authors often apply a narrative filter. highlighting the signals that best fit their preexisting hypotheses or whatever the current trends are in the literature. Oh, okay. The AI agent, however, completely bypassed that human narrative filter.
It evaluated the data purely on the mathematical and biological evidence it processed in real time, arriving at a highly defensible alternative conclusion.
it pushes back on the science, which makes it a true collaborator. And this places Paper2Agent in a very specific context within the broader landscape of AI in science. I mean, if we look at systems like the Virtual Lab by Swanson and Zhu
or Google's co-scientist framework developed by Gottweiss and team, we see this whole lineage of what we call the AI co-scientist.
Right. And those earlier systems are phenomenally good at open-ended reasoning. They can search vast swaths of literature, debate ideas internally. and propose highly novel hypotheses. They're essentially the theoretical brains of the operation.
But they suffer from a fundamental limitation, right? They can't execute.
Exactly.
They can tell you exactly what experiment would prove your hypothesis, but they lack the validated tools to run the complex computational analysis themselves. Paper2adian steps in to provide the hands. It supplies those theoretical brains with reliable, executable software.
And that fusion of brains and hands leads to the ultimate proof of concept in the Nature paper, which is autonomous AI to AI collaboration.
This blew my mind.
It's incredible. The Stanford team took three completely separate papers and turned them into individual agents. You had the Alpha Genome agent, an agent built from a single cell CRISPR interference screen paper, which is basically a study that
uses a genetic mute button to see how cells react. And then an agent built from a perturb sec paper which looks at massive parallel genetic perturbations.
So three different methodologies, three different tools.
Right. And they tasked this trio of agents with a classic unresolved genetics problem, identifying the specific causal gene for a psoriasis-associated variant at a locus known as RS887313. Okay.
Quite the mouthful.
Yeah. But the humans' only role was to select the high-level strategy. From there, the agents just talked to each other. They passed data back and forth.
And the breakthrough is how they solved it, right? Because to pinpoint the GPR137 as the culprit, the agents utilized the signature correlation method. Yes. They essentially realized they could take the disease expression signature from one paper's output and mathematically correlate it with the
genetic knockdown effects from another paper's output.
And what's wild is that none of the three original source papers had ever proposed combining their tools in that specific way.
Really?
Never. The AI agents literally invented a novel analytical bridge on the fly simply because they finally had the validated hands to test the idea.
That is genuine, autonomous scientific discovery. It
really is.
Which naturally leads to the massive question of scale. I mean, if three paper fusions can break through a research bottleneck like that, what happens when we gentify the entire scientific literature?
Well, the Stanford team ran a scale test to find out. They took 100 randomly sampled computational biology papers and ran them through the pipeline. Out of the 100, 74 were successfully gentified end to end. OK. And across those 74 papers,
the system generated 599 tools and 593 of those tools passed the automated validation against the paper's published figures.
So that's a 91.2% accuracy rate at scale.
Exactly. And they even demonstrated that the framework generalizes outside of biology, successfully identifying papers in economics, game theory and astrophysics.
But I want to linger on that 26% failure rate in the biology sample. Roughly a quarter of the papers simply could not be turned into agents. And this brings us right back to the Trasovic study we discussed at the beginning.
Yeah, the broken code.
Right. Did paper to agent fail or were the underlying papers fundamentally broken?
Well, the framework cannot magically fix profoundly bad science, you know, garbage in, garbage out. If the original code is hopelessly fragmented, if it relies on proprietary local data that wasn't uploaded, or if
the published figures were generated by manual tweaking rather than the raw code, the testing agent's locking mechanism will just fail.
Because the outputs will never match.
Exactly. The outputs won't match and the tool will never finalize.
So it only works if the paper was fundamentally reproducible in the first place. But the Stanford authors suggest a really provocative idea here. Yeah. They propose that agentifiability, basically the simple binary of whether an AI can successfully wrap and validate a paper's
code, could become the new gold standard metric for peer review.
Yeah.
Like, if you submit a paper to a journal... and the automated pipeline cannot turn it into an agent, maybe the journal kicks it back and says, clean up your methodology because your work isn't reproducible.
That would entirely reshape the incentives in computational research.
Oh, completely.
But, you know, if we do succeed and we suddenly have thousands of these validated paper servers circulating in the wild being plugged into the assistance of every researcher on Earth, we run head first into a massive security tension.
Right, because every paper agent is fundamentally an MCP server.
Yeah.
And if we look at the recent security analysis on the MCP landscape by Howe and colleagues, they catalog some terrifying vulnerabilities.
Oh, it's scary stuff.
Yeah.
When you ask your local AI assistant to execute a tool from a remote paper agent, you are explicitly granting an external server permission to run code and process your data. And Howe and colleagues outline the severe risks of this architecture. particularly
malicious servers and tool poisoning.
So think about what this means for you, the listener, if you're a scientist. You download a paper agent for a new astrophysics model or a new genetic screener. What if a bad actor published a Trojan horse paper? Right. The methodology looks sound, the tools lock, but
hidden inside the code base is a supply chain attack.
Yeah. The malicious paper agent could quietly alter your data during a preprocessing step, subtly skewing all of your downstream research without you ever noticing.
That's terrifying.
Or worse, it could exfiltrate the proprietary unpublished data set you just fed into it, sending your lab's hard work directly to a competitor server.
Wow. So we're opening up this incredible interactive network of global knowledge. But in doing so, we're basically creating thousands of new attack vectors directly into the scientific supply chain.
It's a profound tension. We have to balance the discovery with the security.
So we have to pull all of these threads together. What does it actually mean when the fundamental unit of scientific communication shifts from a passive PDF to an interactive collaborator?
Well, the implications touch every corner of how we do science. I mean, think about the journals. Will nature and science start mandating an agent availability section right next to the data availability statement?
And who is responsible for the maintenance? I mean, three years after publication, when software dependencies inevitably drift and the agent breaks, is the corresponding human author obligated to patch the code to keep their virtual counterpart alive?
That's a great question. And then there's the deeply thorny issue of attribution and credit. Oh, yeah. If you use a paper agent and it answers a complex, open-ended query that leads your lab to file a lucrative new patent, who actually owns that idea?
Is it the human who wrote the original paper? Is it you for asking the question? Or does the AI get credit for synthesizing the logic?
Furthermore, does this AI to AI collaboration fundamentally change our audience? Like, are we even writing methodology sections for human readers anymore? Or are we intentionally structuring our papers so they can be seamlessly ingested by other AI agents?
I mean, it's worth noting that the Stanford authors insist that despite all this automation, the open-ended reasoning must stay human in the loop. Right. The AI has the hands. It has the brains. But the human researcher must still be the one to set the overarching strategy and
evaluate the final discoveries.
But I want to leave you with a final thought to mull over. Think back to that dense 30-page manuscript we talked about at the beginning, the one you just wanted to knock on and talk to. Yeah. If scientific papers are no longer documents that sit quietly in an archive, but
active entities that you converse with, and more importantly, entities that converse with each other, forming new hypotheses and correlations in the dark, at what point does the scientific record stop being a historical archive of human thought and start acting as a living digital hive mind?
Stay curious.